things we talked about a spectrum
meltdown and they rely on some of the
more advanced ways that the CPU operates
it's probably worth diving down and
actually looking at how a CPU actually
executes the code be right I mean we've
touched on this before we did a video on
pipelining we did a video on caching but
also delve down and see what happens
below the surface when we actually get
our CPU to execute our code let's start
by having a simple example line of code
that we might want to look at what
happen let's take a line of code that
takes a variable let's take a line of
code it's gonna add up a plus B plus C
plus D times e so I've written this in
this sort of see like language so we're
gonna do this calculation now as I'm
sure most of us are aware when we take
that and put into our C compiler run it
it gets converted into the machine code
that the CPU executes so we take that
client of code and then we'd have to
convert that into the machine code and
then the CPU executes that machine code
so a program like this would end up
looking and I'm going to use arm
assembly here just because I know it
better than the anything else perhaps
for the first instruction we would load
the value for memory of a into registers
let's pick our zero we've got 14 or so
of them we can use the 16 of them but
some of them get used for different
things that we don't really use so
although the value of a into our zero
next thing we want to do is you want to
add that to the value of B then after
make sure we'll get the operator
precedence right so we can load the
value of B into a register so let's
loading the value of C here into another
register and we might as well do D and E
as well so load or three come on D and
we'll load our four with E as well and
now we can start adding these things up
multiplying them to produce the actual
result we want now we're going to make
sure we get the precedence right but we
could either start by adding a and B
together then add on C and then multiply
D and E and have them together or we
could do that one first I'm just going
to start going from left to right as
long as the math is right we'll get the
right result so we'll add together a and
B now I put those two values in r0 and
r1 and we need to store the results
somewhere
we are going to need the value of a
again after this so we'll reuse the
register R 0 so we're saying put into R
0 the value of R 0 plus R 1 so this is
adding together storing the result in R
0 so we now added a and B together we
want to add on C and so we could do the
same thing add to R 0 the value in R 0
which is now because of this instruction
a plus B want to add on the value in R 2
there's now about a plus B plus C in our
0 now we need to do the multiplication
and we need to do that separately before
we add it on so we get the right result
so we'll multiply and we'll see we've
got an arm too cheap here so we've got
the multiply instruction there and we
need to put the results on whether it's
use our 5 D which we put in R 3 and E
which we put in R 4 and then we want to
add the result of that onto the value in
our 0 and now our 0 contains the result
of a plus B plus C plus D times E and we
could then store that back into X so
that line of code there at one line of C
code would become what 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 different lines an assembler and I've
numbered them because I'm going to refer
to them at different times so we can say
searching one instruction 5 etc to refer
to the different ones now we might
expect that our CPU will just xu
instruction 1 the new instruction 2
instruction 3 instruction 405 and so on
in order to generate the result and some
cpus do in fact work exactly like that
but actually if you think about what the
cpus and what these descriptions are
actually doing you might think well
actually when i get this first one I've
got to go an access memory and as we
talked about in the caching video many
years ago cache is perhaps a an
old-fashioned English word but it
basically just means a small place where
we can store things so you might use it
to store your hidden treasure if you're
a pirate or to store your food for
winter on a modern CPU probably say
around 200 nanoseconds to actually go
and get the value out of your main
memory and load it into the register now
of course if these are already cached in
the same bit of memory then you may find
that these all execute very quickly we
don't know that
this isn't the only way we could write
this program because
if we take this instruction here
instruction 6 where we do the add of r0
and r1 to add up a and B well we've got
those two values here they're already in
the registers at this point in the
program so there's nothing to stop us
moving this instruction up there and it
would still have exactly the same effect
so instruction 6 could be moved to me
between instructions 2 & 3 and then we
do the next instruction which was the
same as instruction 3 here which would
be LDR R to come of the values in memory
that's representing the letter the
variable see how exactly the same effect
we just moved that instruction earlier
so you could rewrite this program in
various different ways
now why is that interesting
well when we think about how a CPU is
designed and that you will have various
different what impress be termed
execution units within there now one of
them is what's generally referred to as
the ALU or the arithmetic and logic unit
and that's the bit of your CPU that does
addition it does subtraction it does
sort of logical operators and or and so
on but you also have other bits inside
there and one of the bits you'll often
have in a modern CPU is it part of your
CPU that handles loading and storing
values from memory sometimes interact
sometimes they don't now assuming that
they are separate parts of the CPU if we
look back at our instructions here we
execute instruction 1 it uses a load
store you need to get a value for memory
we execute instruction 2 it uses the
load store unit to get a value for
memory instruction 3 it uses a load
store unit to get a value for memory for
uses the load store unit to get a value
for memory 5 uses the load store unit to
get a value for a memory 6 changes and
uses the ALU as 2 7 8 & 9 before
insertion turn uses the load store unit
so we've got a pretty sequential series
the first 5 instructions all execute
using the load store part of the CPU the
next four instructions execute using the
ALU and the final instruction again uses
the load store unit but as we said we
can reorder that into this version here
using instructions w x y and z
differentiate them and we execute the
first instruction instruction w uses a
load store unit instruction X uses a
load store unit instruction Y uses the
ALU restrictions ed uses the load store
unit okay what difference does that make
well let's think about what's happening
when we're using the load store unit the
ALU isn't being used that part of the CV
is just sitting there not being used and
when we're using the ALU the load store
units sitting there not being used
that's what we saw there but does that
have to be the case could we actually
design it and you probably guess the
answer is that yes we can so that while
the load store unit say is being used
that we can run the instructions on the
ALU part as well I'd turn the paper
round and I'm going to draw this as a
sort of timeline so these are our two
units and we've got time running along
this side as well I'm using the computer
for our paper in a radically different
orientation but never mind so we're
going to execute the instructions on
here and the first thing that happens is
that we execute instruction W no problem
that's going to take certain amount of
time to actually that's using the load
store unit to execute it these are being
fetched and decoded and sort of executed
by the different execution units we then
execute the next instruction which is X
and we couldn't execute this any earlier
because the load store unit was being
used to execute that one so no
difference than what we had before we're
using this one after the other we now
come to execute the add instruction now
we can't execute this any earlier than
this point in time because this depends
on the value of registers r0 and r1
which aren't set until this point so we
need those two values so we can start
doing instruction why here now actually
it's an ADD it's not going to take as
long as fetching things from memory
because it's all inside the CPU so we
can use a smaller box and we can put
instruction Y there and this depends on
the value being fetched from there and
I'm just going to show this as an arrow
here but the next instruction load r2
comma C well I doesn't depend on
anything except the value in there
Marie and our load/store units not being
used so if we build our CPU right
there's nothing to start that
instruction being executed at the same
time and that means that actually when
we come to the next instruction which
would be which will be the best
instruction to execute next in this
example let's go back to our program
we've executed instructions one to six
and three already that's w x y&z we've
rewritten the mass let's put instruction
seven here what was instruction seven
and this is now going to become I'm
gonna have to use it's gonna become
instruction a I'll hopefully remember to
say instruction a but you can guess the
colonics are referring to a on its own
is probably the variable if not is
probably the instruction so we can now
execute instruction a and again
instruction a depends on two things it
depends on the value of R 0 which is
going to come from this instruction so
we have to have that ready but it also
depends on the value of R 2 which is
coming from this instruction so we have
to have that ready as well so it can
actually happen any point before this
point in time so this would be the LDR R
2 comma dot and this is the add R 0 and
this is the next add but again we can
start trying to leave more the
instructions because I okay well that's
what instruction for here at the same
time we'll call this instruction B and
so on we put that at that point we can
execute instruction B at the same time
as we do way and I'm really confusing
myself with pens here and so again we've
saved some time because rather than
having to execute that in the same thing
we can do these two things at the same
time now to be able to do this we need
these instructions need to execute on
different execution units we couldn't
for example execute to add instructions
at the same time because we haven't got
to Al use well though there's no reason
why you can build a CPU with two Al use
if you look at modern CPU designs from
Intel AMD arm and cetera they all have
often have multiple Al used or allow you
to do just that
but because the different types we can
execute them at the same time and the
reason we can do that is because they
don't depend
on the results of one to work out the
other so they're working on different
things and they're using different parts
of the CPU and the CPU that enables you
to do this is what's known as a
superscalar CPU because it can run
multiple instructions at the same time
will you continue doing this and we'd
end up we execute instruction B then
we've got to execute instruction C
instruction D uses a multiply and
actually on a CPU probably got a
separate execution unit which does and
multiplies because you can actually do
them faster that way so you have a
multiply unit as well so we can execute
that multiply D up there we think well
okay can we do the other at the same
time well no because we need the result
of that as well so we can then execute
the ad down here before finally and it
just fits on the paper like that so we
can actually squash things up and we're
going to save some time because if you
think about it you have the original
order of the program and here's one I
made earlier all right or as in I'm just
about to draw and Shawn will do some
very clever cutting so even if we had a
superscalar processor we've only got one
load store unit we've only got one al
you really got one multiply unit we
wouldn't have any opportunities with
this program to run two instructions at
the same time so this version of the
program would still take ten
instructions this one still takes ten
instructions but with a superscalar
processor we have the opportunity to
sort of execute two instructions at the
same time because they use different
bits of the CPU now you need to design
the CPU to allow that but that enables
us to speed things up a little bit
because while this is working to get the
value for memory we can execute some
more instructions now that's all very
well and superscalar processors started
to appear in the mid 90s things like the
six eight thousand and sixty the Pentium
I think was superscalar but they require
the code to be written in a way that
enables this to happen so this program
wouldn't have been able to do anything
this one would but as we said when we
were developing this we could work out
which instructions we could move around
to get that speed up based on
what those instructions depended on so
this instruction we said what what six
became why only depended on the values
of R 0 and R 1 which has been set by
instructions 1 & 2 so we can move that
earlier without affecting anything in
our program because it only depended on
those 2 values so we can either do this
in the compiler or by hand if you write
in the assembly yourself like we just
did here or it's possible to let the CPU
work it out and so what a modern CPU
does what's called an out of water CPU
is reorders the instructions without
supposedly breaking the rules of what
each instruction does so it'll still
execute it as if it was written like
this and it won't change break any of
the rules of that but it will say well
hang on it will spot that this
instruction could happen earlier and so
move it earlier to gain some of that
parallelism in fact then execute them
together at the same time and that works
generally get well but as we saw with
things like Spector and meltdown if you
allow things to happen too far earlier
and start doing what's called
speculative evaluation where you say
okay I've got the stuff I need to
execute it now I don't if I need the
result but I might do so I'll execute it
anyway and then if I need it I've
already done it and if I don't need it
while I was still waiting for this to
come in anyway so it doesn't matter that
I've done it I've not lost any time well
then it's turned out that you can have
sort of side channels where you can sort
of see that that's happened or not which
is caused a few issues with computing it
goes along here like this intersects the
curve somewhere else flips over and it's
over here so this is for G now we won't
look at any more right the edge of a
formula for this is just mathematics to
do with lines and the tangent of this
curve it's actually not very complicated
the point is that what we're doing is by
multiplying G